philippe starck bonsoir c'est ta
nouvelle femme
oui on vient de se marier hier elle
s'appelle comment arava chaque à la jma
petit arabe et l'entendre sur nos
reliefs chili dix ans c'est moderne
c'est moderne est ce que tu viens là
c'est oui oui je n'ai jamais pu
supporter l'idée du canapé pour moi
c'est vraiment le le symbole même de
l'oeuvre de l'habitat bourgeois comme ça
et je ne comprends pas à mon histoire
ie7 une position totalement archaïque
les paysans de l'ancien temps qui était
en ligne le long du mur comme ça pour
regarder ne sait pas que vous parlez
l'intéressent klaus klipp c'est à toi
calgary ce canapé
non je des boys bonnaire t'aurais pas
dessiner ça je soupçonne que non ça vaut
combien canapé stack belle cette bourse
est très nouveau je crois que le premier
vient juste de sortir à milan il ya un
mois et je ne sais pas parce que comme
tout comme tout ce que je fais j'espère
c'est un prix juste
je ne sais pas si c'est pas cher qui se
fait chair d'abord comment la portance
et la justesse du produit c'est à dire
qu'il peut
une ferrari vaut son prix justement il
ya d'autres marques qui vole les gens
quand ils achètent une mercedez est
toujours plus économique qui nous de
voiture alors qu'il était actuellement
la première personne qui est venu aux
bains douches à l'époque le comment ça
s'est passé de première fois que venu
ici pour le faire oui of vahid y avait
les fabris et jacques qui à l'époque
était antiquaire et qui venait ici
acheter le bar je crois le bar en bas et
ils sont ressortis en disant oh non
droit incroyable c'est un bal douche
c'était un vrai bain 12 challenge à une
boîte c'est un vrai non non c'était un
bain douche c'était surtout je crois un
endroit de baptême par immersion si je
ne me trompe c'est pour cette là haut il
y avait encore une petite baignoire avec
un escalier de rampone art et donc il
est arrivé il a dix ans j'ai vu au local
extraordinaire qu'est ce qu'on pourra en
faire et
et c'est là où tout l'idée le concept
badouche est venu où on a amené il ya
des gens sont groupés benin s'occuper de
la musique et ainsi de suite
il ya vraiment eu un esprit vaduz qui
s'est fait et bien drôle il faut dire
aux normes et un autre a été celui qui
avait fait la main bleue la main jaune
et maillot jean pas la main jaune en la
main bleue la main je n'en attendais pas
du tout bah non parce qu'on m'avait
demandé de faire une boîte de nuit la
plus belle du monde je les fais et le
jour de l'ouverture je me suis aperçu
que le type en ce temps là les faits un
roller frink jour du roller skate et
comme je déteste tous les sports néo
américain où tout le monde est à la mode
pour deux mois sur des patins à
roulettes comme des imbéciles
évidemment c'était pas du tout mon
projet on s'est connu à façade ya dix
ans je me soigne la première fois que je
t'ai vu je vais expliquer que finalement
les gens habités toujours dans des
grottes parce qu'un appartement dans un
ancien immeuble s'est jamais qu'une
qu'un espace en forme de grottes bien se
verront contraints passionnel maintenant
à ccc c'est tout le problème foncier
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
on continue à construire des grottes
c'est à dire que quand on fait des murs
en plâtre vous voyez un maçon portugais
qu'est-ce qui fait prendre un petit bois
de la pierre il le met dans des sacs il
aux transports qui le mélange à de l'eau
et il essaye de refaire de la pire lice
mais la liste lapierre par définition
n'est pas fait pour être miss et donc
poussa est un énorme non sens en tout
cas un incroyable archaïsme et il faut
absolument que ça change c'est à dire
que l' architecture deviennent
authentiquement moderne 6 mai mécaniste
pour la bonne raison qu'aujourd'hui les
gens travaillent un tir de leur vie si
ce n'est plus simplement pour se payer
leur coquille
la coquille d'escargot les hattab
seulement scandaleux parce que ces
sommes c'est cette énergie qu'il dépense
à celle pour elf à votre choses donc il
ya vraiment une idée aujourd'hui
politique de ce que doit devenir l'
architecture pourra regretter que les
gens soient esclaves de leur coquille
alors les toques de façade je t'ai
rencontrée j'ai rencontré jean bad vous
avez
heureusement réussi tous les deux mais
dans les années qui ont suivi quand je
te rencontrer dans des dans des boîtes
de nuit ou dans des soirées tu me
racontes et toujours tu sais des choses
en arabie séoudite à dallas partout et
des fois je me demandais s'il était pas
mythomane parce que j'ai tellement
merveilleux c'est arrivé alors qu'est ce
qui s'est passé depuis dix ans non moi
je suis quelqu'un de curieux c'est à
dire que j'adore moi je ne travaille pas
je vous en fais mon compte rejoindre l'
architecture du design de pouce à moi je
suis avant tout un aventurier créatif
j'espère un rêveur autrement dit qui vit
et qui se transporte dont le véhicule et
la création véhicule pour connaître des
gens parce que j'aime j'aime l'humain
pour vivre des aventures et donc j'ai eu
en effet il ya très très longtemps
j'étais bien content parce qu'à l'époque
j'étais totalement ruiné on est
toutefois déjà rentré dans le tour du
monde de deux ans à quoi la rentée
cardin 7 voilà c'est ça et on est rentré
ce tour du monde on était strictement
lessivé et par une chance absolument
incroyable il y à un émir qui est venue
de josé pour pourquoi mais pourquoi il
est arrivé et m'a dit monsieur monsieur
l'ingénieur philippe il faudrait me
décorer mon boeing j'ai fais où je vous
dirais plaisir maps devrait montrer
comment je supportais plus une histoire
de psychanalyste je crois en gros nous a
vraiment tout tout est avocat au mollet
c'est pour ça que c'est à dire je les
prix comme ressemble est quand ça
commence à ne plus l'être tir que ça
j'étais c'était mon seul client de ce
genre et sa durée sa durée de trois ans
pas plus parce qu en fait l'idée c'est
que là bas ils ont toujours trouvé de
cette tare que c'était le fada ces
revenus comprennent mon style n'a
strictement aucun rapport avec leur
désir saoudiens n'ont donc ça s'hérite
ou ça était simplement une petite
aventure mais qui est toujours très
intéressante comme toutes les aventures
nom d'allah ça a été bien plus bien plus
important puisque c'est des familles de
pétrole est en fait c'est la famille qui
sert de modèle à la houe et sa famille
hunt wins rudolph merci neeson est
propre et nadja losc cabaye qui monte
qui m'ont appelé
avec tous les fastes que ça peut
représenter à l'époque parce que je
crois que da la semapa de sinistrés par
la crise va encore soupçonne et donc ils
m'ont dit voilà alors je suis descendu
de l'avion il ya des limousines noires
bang bang bang bang et ils m'ont promené
ils m'ont dit choisissez la ville est à
nous je dis très bien moi je choisir
mais pourquoi faire un hymne à côté on
s'embête et on s'embête alors on a lu
dans le journal dans le nord du new york
times que vous êtes le roi de la nuit
j'ai compris que j'allais où s'agitent à
la campagne avec ma femme m'a finalement
vous êtes le roi des nuls c'est de
marquer dans le journal en gros d'accord
qu'est ce qu'on dit qu'on va écouter on
pense que pour lancer une ville il faut
de la nuit il faut l'esprit de la nuit
il fait noon la plus belle boîte de nuit
du monde alors dont jouit cet endroit
dont l'un avait choisi de tourner parce
qu'en bonne europe 1 je crois toujours
dans down town et on a en effet lens on
a fait cet endroit qui a été
terriblement compliqué parce que ceux
qui ont des fous furieux 3 grammes de
cocaïne par jour et par personne saab et
nous ça s'abîme toujours un peu le
raisonnement en plus à des fils à papa
donc c'est jamais très facile mais ils
ont pas de script nécessité dans le
temps et dans les résultats en fabron au
bout d'une d'une offre une aventure
incroyable mais incroyable digne du
western
on a
fait cet endroit et j'y suis retourné il
y à quelques temps un an ou deux ça
marche très bien et j'ai eu comme le
grand bonheur que les gens me remercient
et en effet c'était le but puisqu'il
fallait changer l'esprit de la lys et
échanger et d'allaoui les émirs il ya eu
dallas et après qu'est ce qui s'est
passé bon non c'était vous je sais pas
qu'est ce que tu attends c'est un
pigiste aucune mémoire ça c'est pas les
meubles d'entrée les bas l'elysée cost
et plein plein de choses ils vont
travailler le poisson une centaine de
projets par an j'en dis tout le temps
leur architecture
bah c'est pas que je me lance dans
l'architecturé de style architecture qui
me lancer dans les mandats rousset ou
ces délais les clients d des gens des
japonais des américains qui voient ce
que j'ai fait en intérêts qui le disent
mais quand on est capable de faire ça ce
sont sept ans la structure alors en
effet j'ai eu des quelques premières
appréhensions lors d'un projet dix ans
que je suis capable de le faire ou pas
et quand on arrive toujours frey candide
et qu'on a deux trois trucs à dire aux
trouve des solutions très forte
abstention très intéressante et donc on
a fait le premier immeuble haut à tokyo
qui va être fini là dans deux mois et
j'en suis très très très très fier pour
la même raison
j'ai vraiment l'impression d' amener
quelque chose une vraie fraîcheur
architecture c'est une drôle de bête
vous pouvez essayer de décrire l'objet
le nom le pr nom de code dans le bureau
s'appelait de dia le deuxième jeu green
monsters of the bayou le monstre vert du
bayou c'est-à-dire l'espèce de monstre
qui vit dans les marécages qui se
nourrit de cadavres qui un jour détruira
tout le tout le sud de l'amérique
et maintenant il s'appelle le nombre
définitif c'est nani n'a ni la nina ni
ça veut dire l'innommable quentin
japonais c'est parce qu'ils voient
cantina pearl regatta nimani est donc
cette un immeuble complètement
biomorphiques complètement de formes
organiques vicieux en perpétuelle des
compositions il est recouvert d'auxi 2 à
r cette décomposition cool avec l'autre
fuient et se et se répand dans le sol de
granit noir où il ya des microfissures
qui ont été faites au laser et qui
raconte son histoire est une autre
histoire qui va s'inscrire au fil du
temps et de cet ovaire qui coule partout
et c'est aussi le premier immeuble
prédateurs du
monde puisque j'ai volé par un parent
par une astuce de la loi j'ai volé
l'espace du terrain d'à côté c'est à
dire que mon immeuble et diagonale et
surplombe l'autre du piratage total la
laverie ce qu'on peut le comprendre
la scène d'emma sinon elle laissait les
meubles on à la destinée de tabouret qui
marche très très bien très très très
bien et très beau et j'ai été très
violent de l'argent neuf ans sait
combien gagnez vous mesdemoiselles et
donc voit j'étais très jaloux parce
qu'il a fallu actes que j'attends de
trente six ans pour avoir un meuble
lelangue injecté en une seule pièce
engelures et talc et arrêtent
technologie pour le designer et elle l'a
eue à 8 ans ça m'a bien énervé et là on
sort chez flos en italie dans deux mois
une lampe jallum quand j'ai cette houle
et des superbes attentes
pourquoi perdre son temps finalement
parce que m'amuse à faire ce que je fais
et donc c'est très drôle c'est bien je
perds pas mon temps je me denis
l'impression de le gagner ni la passion
de perdre je vis jma muges destine on
s'agite pas maintenant on va voir
quelque chose que tu as fait amsterdam
est en cours et amsterdam
tu t'en souviens à peu de choses près
oui tu sais ce tramway je le crois pas
que ce n'est pas toi qui appelle non non
non moi j'essaie monsieur devant
parce que l'on voit ça c'est quelque
chose de très moderne on doit réaménager
un bâtiment au mieux d'amsterdam qui
s'appelle de var s'est placé vraiment
comme un arc de triomphe c'est vraiment
un bâtiment central donc tout à fait
sensible les les gens sont sales partie
de leur histoire de leur culture
et c'est un projet très diagonale parce
que c'est un studio de télévision
professionnel mais qui est à la fois
publique dans la mesure où ça va
ressembler un espèce de grand café comme
on pourrait dire le café costes
sauf que c'est un studio de télévision
alors à plein des tâches est assez
sophistiqué mais c'est très c'est très
intéressant parce que c'est très complet
c'est très haut polymorphe comme ça on
est cher au world first we hollande
that's why pour un petit toit de santos
mystère qui failli don't work mort un
before we the hole homme bat na waïe à
marie à nice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'en dirai pas plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un décors d'opéras ou deux joueurs
de ce mot c'est un certain à face à face
un combat on a cette espèce d'énorme
escaliers minérale dur masculin
oppressif quasiment fascisant on a en
face comme un défi cette espèce de mur
de capitons des mesures et étouffant
comme ça incliné assez assez féminin
mais dur aussi
et ils sont ils sont face à face comme
ça ils se regardent le tout après et
coiffée par cette mégastructure qui est
un petit peu ce qu'il rs qui rattache ce
drame au sol alors en fait tout ça est
tout à fait et japonais tout ça c'est
une c'est une violence et une mise en
scène tout à fait japonaise le skill et
ce qui les choque énormément ici ce qui
fait cette espèce d'émotion dans tokyo
c'est le fait que l'emploi des matières
cette espèce d'acajou comme ça mélangé
avec ses velours rouge
ils n'ont pas du tout l'habitude de ça
alors c'est gégé truquer les cartes mais
en gardant la même la même violence sont
arrogés sens commun avec eux
ni and so ifaith ce fine alcatel my
friend hi lo c'est exclu
le sperme à 15
of which iam 7 à ivry
l'alsace avait maintenant nous allons
goûter louis arcaraz mme verveer a
besoin de recycler la deutsche messe a
été dite my way et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu